[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the way i am obsessed with this video
jackson wang that was the monster new
single from the magic man himself who
joins me now dude i have this on heavy
rotation the video is so killer congrats
on the single blow talk to me about the
inspo for the song and also for that
visual i mean it's uh i'm i'm i'm having
this album this later this year called
magic man and that's just like the
beginning of it and uh it's about
mystery
uh temptation and also confusion
[Music]
do you feel liberated because of this
song
i mean yes definitely the concept and
everything i'm free i'm free and i've
never been this raw ever in my life for
the past eight years i've been living
the commercial life i've been like you
know schedules shows after shows it's
like a loop and
that's why like you know eight and nine
years of that i got to a point where i
lost
mentally i lost everything like i was
lost i didn't know what to do
and i was a person that
i you know whenever i deal with stress i
used to not talk with anybody because i
feel like yo i'm just gonna find the
solution and i'm just gonna solve it but
it got to a point that
um with the positive energy friends
around me that they gave me that they
said they forced and they insist to sit
me down and and talk with me and if it's
the first time in my life that i felt
that connection
and
and i start to you know that inspired me
and
i'm like yeah you know whatever
i had before whatev whoever i was before
screw that you know and and now i'm i'm
the new me and i i'm allowing myself to
accept it and that's magic man i love it
and it's magical right i was gonna ask
you because obviously this video
introduces your fans to magic man in
this pursuit right has he helped you
kind of not only work through those
feelings but has he also helped to i
don't know create some different sounds
and just play around yeah
definitely just i used to this is a
thing whatever i whatever i did in the
past i always think about
oh what if this what if that what is
this too much overthinking yes but this
time it's just like screw it you know if
this is what is this is what i feel
inside
what what my mind is telling me let's go
absolutely and it's paying off like this
video is just it's giving me everything
you like it i love it i love it i love
the styling i love the choreography how
much fun was it to film that video with
all those very talented
amazing talented dancers they're artists
and and you know cloud 88 team wang
sublime we everyone worked so hard on it
and and me as an artist like there's a
limit that i can do you know but
everyone completing this puzzle together
it's just it felt like magic yeah right
you know you said that you were in a
different place a year ago right and you
actually recently just wrote a very
emotional note to your fans talking
about you know where you were then and
where you are now so where would you say
you are now heading into the release of
magic man i'm ready you're ready ready i
finished my album and um i thank to all
my supporters and fans that has been
with me since day one when you're in
your very negative moments you you think
about wow like all these my supporters
and my fans that has been you know uh
engaging with me supporting me
my music and me as a person it just
feels
i have someone to hug you'll be
performing at coachella i hear what does
it mean to be able to step onto that
team this is crazy crazy like yeah it's
once in a lifetime man and i'm very
excited at the same time nervous and
are you nervous yes i am but it's like a
good nervousness yeah you know like i
can't wait to go out there and enjoy
and and kill it you know like for myself
you know you gave me you have
collaborated with so many amazing
artists major laser gucci mane is there
anyone else you're dying to work with
and i would like to work on a song with
you really how did you know i could sing
and dance i can always tell your magic
man yourself i'll do whatever i i'll
just be in the background i'll just be
in the background and do magic tricks
[Music]
[Music]
how does it feel knowing that you have
the highest charting solo artist debut
from china with your debut album in 2019
yeah i just feel i'm never satisfied
with my work you know like i always feel
like
and every time i'm i try to top my
previous self
and
more than i think music itself it's art
like more than regions it's music is
music you know i'm chinese myself so
uh i mean i want to share this is like
you know the reason i'm here you know
just going traveling everywhere trying
to share my music to to to
i hope you know one day i can connect
east and the west as a bridge you know
the and and
for people uh in the east knowing that
oh this is really what's happening in
the west more than music and and and the
same air same way around uh uh
west in the east you know like so
this is what i've been trying to do and
what i believe in and hopefully you know
magic man well you know it is more than
music too because you do so many things
you're a true creative and a true artist
i mean you're a producer you're a
fashion designer creative director
you're of course a member of got7 i mean
what can't you do what can't you do i
can't be the host of this show
phew because you know what i need this
job so you know what i'll let me handle
the interview it'll be amazing if we
co-host one one episode don't throw at
me with a good time let's do it will you
come back and do that with me anytime
let's co-host the download together all
right i'll be in one of your music
videos and then you come back and you
host the show with me right and the
whole show is about like
east okay
i love that yes yes yes yes all right uh
a couple more questions because when i
was you know we're learning so much
about you and i didn't realize that you
were a fencer but not just you're like a
great fencer right it was okay i mean
you ranked 11th in the 2010 summer youth
olympics
um i mean i could have done better
i mean
all those friends that that competed
with me they're like uh
olympian uh gold medalist right now and
and it's just amazing you know see
seeing them how how great they are in
their career and and congrats guys
that's awesome do you feel like you
still kind of apply the things you
learned in fencing in some of your
choreography i think the mentality okay
because i born and raised because both
my parents their their national team are
athletes right and they met
because of that too so like growing up
you know in in that family it's just my
head space is
you know when i'm concentrating when i'm
devoted on something like it go 100
percent and and and even though it sucks
in the middle but you know i believe
that one day one day i i'll make it you
know it's that mentality of not letting
noises or whatever negatives uh
negativity you know distract me jackson
wang you are it okay and the fans love
you they adore you i can't wait to hear
more from you guys jackson wang blow is
out now the the the next album the magic
man is out later this year thank you
guys
my pleasure i'm i'm obsessed with you i
love you oh my god you gotta come back
you have to come back for real though
you